on entend le président dire qu'il fait
les choses avec beaucoup d'humilité
humilité et prononcé trois fois je
voulais aussi
avec beaucoup d'humilité de lucidité
soumettre ma candidature aux françaises
et aux français
on le voit parler de lui-même dans le
genre autosatisfait je crois qu'on n'a
pas fait beaucoup mieux jusqu'à présent
qu'on a des détenus sur une guerre qui
permet de mettre des ddd pré-générique
on a des montages junk est comme sur les
séries avec des mouvements de tremblay
de caméras on a
aussi une prise de vue qui est une prise
de vue que les réalisateurs identifie
comme étant faite par des caméras qui
sont du niveau de celle du cinéma et
pourquoi évidemment pour une raison
évidente c'est qu'on veut faire de
emmanuel macron mieux qu'un homme
politique un héros de série c'est
vraiment pour s'adresser à un public qui
est friand très consommateurs très
boulimique de ses séries américaines et
qui a un univers mental finalement des
fictions et plus on va dire intéressés
par la communication politique un peu à
la partie
le réalisateur d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
stéphane gilliot est un réalisateur
assez doué c'est un garçon qui a fait
obtenir sur bfm tv qui est un format qui
parle beaucoup d'automobiles mais qui
est très fictionné et puis il a aussi
fait sur france télévisions les
incroyables pouvoirs du corps humain qui
est un magazine très fictionné lui aussi
donc ils maîtrisent ce réalisateur très
bien les codes de la fiction vous voyez
les bars coop seebach scop c'est
vraiment
l'
usage de la fiction il n'y a pas autre
chose pour dire la fiction que l'on est
dans des formats de fiction que m des
bars cops qui nous permet d'avoir un
format qui est au delà même du 16/9
on voit le président qui qui la hait
dans des délais qui cultive son son
style décontracté sympathique
on voit ce président très bienveillant
avec son personnel de sécurité avec les
gens qui l'entourent il est en train de
cultiver une posture de paix de
président chaleureux humain soucieux de
des gens ensuite on va l'entendre parler
débriefer c'est le propre exercice qu'il
vient de faire c'est vraiment
l'archétype du président qui parle de
lui-même liste puis se satisfait qui
donne de la posture de cette dynamique
un peu cool à destination des gens qui
le connaissent pas bien mais dont il
veut faire voir que c'est inscrit dans
l'humain c'est un président qui a une
attitude détendue comme le président
obama
alors là on est au début de l'épisode 3
on est dans ce que l'on appelle un pré
générique qui doit être un climax
on voit emmanuel macron qui est en
concentration sur lui-même il rate il
inspire fort etc on a l'impression d'un
boxeur qui va monter en scène
et puis à un moment où ils se
précipitent hop on a le générique de
cette fiction vraiment l'art dans les
codes d'écriture très être un netflix et
puis ensuite on va le voir finalement
présenté son programme on a aucune
communication sur le fond on n'a aucune
mise en avant des propositions on n'a
aucun échange avec des français non on
n'a rien sur le fond c'est volontaire je
crois que c'est le parti pris ou on va
montrer le président et le sublimer dans
son exercice de rôle de chef de l'état
on se souvient que victor hugo si vous
voulez dans l'histoire de la
communication avait eu une phrase
magnifique qui disait le la forme c'est
le fond qui remonte à la surface on
était au 19e siècle au 20e siècle
uma thurman qui a dit eh bien le médium
c'est le message là c'est pire que tout
c'est le message c'est le médium le
message c'est netflix et voilà vous avez
un président qui est un héros de fiction
et sahin une destination la destination
c'est le public jeune ça part un peu du
principe que c'est facile de draguer les
jeunes il suffit de leur jeter de la
poudre aux yeux entre guillemets il
suffit de leur faire miroiter des
étoiles dès que des codes 2d de plate
forme pour que ça fonctionne infesté la
famille la petite enfance cru à l'école
dans l'information c'est éviter que les
inégalités nouveaux produits
bonjour
comme par hasard figurez vous il
rencontre un sportif alors qui lui ne
transpire pas ce qui est assez curieux
pour quelqu'un qui est censé avoir
beaucoup couru le président s'interroge
sur calais ses performances alors
combien tu as fait et ils sont en train
de comparer leurs performances mutuelle
trois heures ceux-ci trois heures cela
est immédiatement après on a deux jeunes
femmes très sympathique qui viennent et
qui disent le président
évidemment on voit qu'il ya un côté très
très artificielle très composé sais
c'est pas évidemment ce ne sont pas des
rencontres faites par hasard évidemment
d'ailleurs quand le quand le chanceux
des zooms un petit peu on découvre qu'il
ya des agents de sécurité un peu partout
enfin tout ça est à la limite de comment
dirais-je de la mise en scène un peu
balourde quoi c'est à dire que ça ça
respire le carton pâte que je voudrais
pas une écriture de mick ligne je
voudrais un truc plus en effet
d'événements sportifs un peu plus
charnel qui est une forme de moi qui dis
merci sent bien que comme ça et tu
commences et la part d'acs alors là on
entend le président qui se préoccupe de
son prochain big thing grands rendez
vous on est vraiment dans l'archétype du
président qui n'a pas de retenue dans
leurs lignes de posture présidentielle
et puis qu'il mélange aussi sa vie
privée puisque on voit la brigitte
macron sa femme qui le rejoint et la
brise marine lp contours et les deux
sens là c'est lui faire de la une petite
plaisanterie évidemment tout ça un
mélange des genres c'est absolument pas
l'exercice gaulliste de l'autorité où on
avait un président en majesté un
président qui ne parlait que de son
travail est évidemment pas de la sphère
privée on n'imagine pas yvonne de gaulle
rentré avec le président qui était là
paf et chaque et la voyais jouer mettre
dans un dans une configuration sportive
je veux un meeting de configuration
sportive quelques années plus tard on se
dit que la politique a bien changé